I was talking with the novelist and your
great collaborator about what she wanted
to do with this book and she said it was
very important for her to write the
screenplay herself because she was
afraid of what the movie could become
she didn't want it to be kind of an
over-the-top stalker film or a kind of
superhero mom story I read the book I
loved it um my own little boy was the
same age or roughly as Jack and so it
was sort of wide open to this beautiful
character and I just decided I would
tell her because we knew the book was
quite a big deal and we thought our
chances would be pretty slim but at the
same time I thought well nothing
ventured nothing gained and at least if
I have to sit in a cinema watching
somebody else's version of it and I
couldn't quite decide which would be
worse if it was great or if it was awful
I didn't know which I would hate more I
think if it was great to be perfectly
honest I would hate that even more um
but so I wrote of this letter and I
think what I said and it was yet it
happened to me in keeping with what she
thought which was that that we should
use as little as possible in terms of
trickery or or very overt technique to
still keep this the boys story but to do
it very naturalistically so that all of
the other aspects that are so so
beautifully they're you know they're the
metaphorical aspects and the things that
make the story about childhood and love
and being a parent and growing up that
that would all be there but but be there
very delicately and I I think talked
about the same fear that you could
either make this a bleak true crime
story or a kind of voyeuristic story or
you can end up with something very sappy
and sentimental and luckily she was we
were both kind of on the same page when
I read it I had very very vivid pictures
in my head as I read it even from early
on a novel once I kind of worked out
what she was doing in that that you had
this hopeful little child in the middle
of this very dark world and I had very
strong images of what of what the two of
them would look like together and how we
could kind of move from a very intimate
connection to his way of seeing things
to to more of a God's eye view and and
more of Amma's I view but I but I felt
very strongly that's so
if it would really be there in in the
pictures and that we sometimes that it
was sometimes diminished that the power
of our own medium by thinking our
literature has all these kind of
descriptive devices and it has this
ability to like absolutely tell you what
it wants to tell you in a way that film
doesn't but actually we have phases and
we have passage of time and the
atmosphere in the room and and the sort
of palpable feeling between Bree and
Jake and so my my Pecha my guess was
that that we could capture that point of
view but we could do it in films terms
and it would still with with lots of
reconfiguration and stuff but but but
actually you know I think people were
coming in and saying I mean you can't
just be there in the room with them you
will have to intercut you'll have to
like flashbacks or or you'll have to
find some device to capture the first
person thing you'll have to allow for
their you know use a little bits of CG
or like really put the magic out there
into the picture but again I don't think
that would have been as powerful is just
really believing these characters I
didn't have any answers to anything
which is my favorite way of going into
something is feeling a little this
excitement because there's so much
unknown and a lot of fear that goes
along with this of this constant sort of
can we do this and can we can we tell
this honestly can we respect the
material do we have the knowledge to
fully understand this there's so many
factors in this story that are on that
are so outside of our daily lives but
the thing in exploring it further and
going through all of these long
conversations many philosophical
conversations and then many factual
conversations with experts that knew
what would actually be happening in this
type of situation we were then able to
find the universal and that was always
the heart of it was how do we instead of
making this something that's bizarre
we make it something that's very much
like home
and so the two of us were a great
balance because I've only been a child
but I have a very close relationship to
my mother and I am I'm very curious
about my mother and our relationship and
so I had a lot of thoughts about it and
a lot of thoughts about
ma as joy and what that relationship
would be like at home but the that sort
of complicated tangible relationship
between MA Jack that's in room when you
see them together that was that was more
of Lenny's creation and helping me
understand because I haven't been
through it so we became a great balance
that I could sort of be an expert on one
half of it and he could be one on the
other and we could combine those those
two but when you're I'm curious about
what you're talking about is when you
talk about your mom with whom you're
really close when you're doing a role
like this you were in variability are
kind of thinking about your own
childhood about a month before I we
started shooting I had decided to take
about a month to just be at home and see
what it felt like to quiet my mind and
have no real distractions that were
outside of doing these really difficult
workouts that were exhausting and having
my six meager meals a day that I was
doing on this diet to sort of slim down
and and so in that quiet I remembered
when I was seven years old and my mom
packing up our old Mercedes and driving
from Sacramento to Los Angeles and we it
was me and my mom and my sister was like
three or four and we had almost nothing
I mean we had a couple pairs of pants
each a couple shirts I think my sister
each we each had a toy and we lived in
the space that was not much bigger than
room maybe twice twice the size but
rooms not that big so twice the size is
not a lot of space there was a bed that
came out from the from the wall a Murphy
bed it was a Maria a Murphy bed but if
the bed came out that was it took up
pretty much all the room but I
remembered it as being one of the
greatest times of my life it was one of
my fondest memories of I really related
to when Jack says oh you know room went
in every direction and never stopped
that's how I felt another power of
imagination my mom was able to take
these small things that we had these
couple of toys and these four walls and
turned it into something that was just
magical and I had my mom all to myself
and that was the greatest gift of all is
that she was my hero and I got to see
her do all these cool things all the
time
and one aspect that I had I guess shut
out because I knew I wasn't supposed to
know about it was I we all three slept
in the same bed and I remembered waking
up in the middle of the night and to my
mom and he's choking sobs covering her
mouth so that I couldn't hear and I knew
not to say anything and I just
remembered thinking this reminds me of
what it's like to have my toys taken
away and it wasn't until I don't know I
mean I guess I knew some pieces of the
story but I didn't know the full scope
of it until much later in my life where
I realized that the move was sort of
inspired for my dad asking for a divorce
and my mom packed up our car with a
couple thousand dollars in her pocket
knowing nobody in Los Angeles and her
reaction to it instead of being sort of
down and out about it was to create this
very big world for us that then was a
world that she could it was a projection
that she could live in and it was such
an aha moment for me of oh that's my
into this story and this is how I know
that there's a universal nature to it
because I lived it and now I can
actually go back and relive this memory
but through my mother's eyes and and it
brought me so much closer to her I mean
I called her every couple of days
sobbing just so I'm on my knees begging
for forgiveness
for all of the things that I didn't know
that you can't know as a kid but that
you hate that you didn't know when
you're thinking about that and you meet
Jacob Tremblay who plays your son of
this film what was that experience like
and what were the concerns that you had
and planed the mother to this boy that
you've never met my concern was that he
wasn't gonna like me that was it because
kids are so simple and I think the
reaction is so visceral and comes from
the expression on your face and where
your lines are and the way your face
kind of illuminates when you're happy I
know that that it's so it's so simple
for them and so I couldn't do any
trickery I couldn't this was not someone
who was like my age that I could be like
throw around you know some cool
references and hope that it worked out
go get a drink together this is a child
who's just gonna pick up on my immediate
energy and the only thing that I could
do was just drop any facade possible and
just play and it worked really well I'm
really glad that we got on so well and
it very quickly became became comrades
and became such partners during the
making of this movie and our
relationship was so purely loving and
helpful for one another and we enjoyed
every second we spent together that I
remember distinctly maybe a month and
half into shooting where he was like
really confused as to who I was to him
like did not and that's where the term
co-worker came from because then it was
like okay great we're working together
he's my coworker because I was his
friend and he would get confused
sometimes by that like why don't I yell
at Bri like no that's MA and it was like
having these moments of him going we do
everything together we play together we
have lunch together we have breakfast
together
she knows all of my siblings she's part
of my family she's my friend but she's
also playing my mom who is this person
in my life and so we had to just kind of
shake hands on coworker and then it
became very easy that we could be like
great job co-worker it was a very simple
way of going about things